hey guys welcome back to Nagar park the
very last video of Nagar park actually
and he all notice that I am NOT going to
do much interesting stuff in this video
it's more or less just going through the
park and finishing the things that still
needed to be finished which is mostly a
bit of foliage and a bit of rock work
here just all kinds of smaller things
especially in the Dutch area though it's
mostly the filling up of the area of all
of the empty crawl spaces that I still
have which means lots of trees and
bushes new plot elements which are just
about the only really interesting and
new parts of this video and it's also a
really short video and I'll talk about
all of the reasons why this is such a
short video and why this is going to be
the last video right now basically since
I'm going to Gamescom I don't have any
other time left to actually finish this
Park and since I made the palace a day
ago which was supposed to be the day
that I would finish Necker Park and get
some extra stuff done and get more
things done then I'm doing now I don't
really have any time to finish this park
off properly and hell I don't even have
much time to finish these videos of
properly so I'm just doing what I can
here to at least finish the park in its
current state in a way that I was always
planning to do so and just covering up
the areas which I can't work on anymore
with lots of foliage or coming soon
signs things like that the park
definitely won't be looking unfinished
or like it still needs a lot of work to
actually look presentable but I'm not
going to go with the original plans the
Scandinavian plan was scrapped quite a
while ago and some other refurbs of
other sections of the park that I was
hoping to maybe do are also not going to
happen I'm just going to really call it
a day here so um yeah that's what's
going on here now this being the last
episode it is a kind of a nice kind of
video to look back a bit on it and talk
a bit about my future plans again
because I don't really have any other
opportunities in which I can do so
really so as a final conclusion of sorts
of this series
I am quite happy with the park it's
something which I am probably not going
to end up doing again in planet coaster
though at least not anytime soon the
idea behind this park was mostly to make
something on a very small scale and just
keep it on the realism and on the
details but I always found during the
park that I was like looking for a bit
more of a challenge and while it
definitely was a challenge to make this
bike the way it is especially making all
of the pieces in the game as
unrecognizable and add some extra
touches of realism that the game itself
doesn't have yet it didn't really feel
as challenging when it comes to larger
landscapes or more unique and creative
architecture that kind of stuff and it's
really just really limited to what I
wanted to make for a small realistic
family park so the next couple of
projects and I'm not entirely sure what
they're going to be like it all kind of
depends on what I find in alpha-3 and
what I think works best with it the next
couple of projects are going to be on a
much larger scale and bit more creative
doing some more unusual things again and
trying to step out of that's keeping
everything 100% realistic kind of bubble
and there are a couple of plans which I
am thinking about one of them is to make
a very large park very much like Disney
but probably more like Universal Studios
Islands of Adventure since water is
coming in alpha 3 and a lot of new
themes that can really make that sort of
very large fantasy themed park and
another option which is to harm will
just be to go completely fantasy have a
park which is huge with all sorts of you
to roller coasters that you wouldn't
realistically build because of their
costs and large structures just kind of
go haywire just for fun it's either one
of those two and which ones it's going
to be kind of just depends on what I
feel like and what turns out to be the
thing that works but um after this very
small-scale park I definitely am looking
for something bigger but I'm still quite
happy with maker Park even though it
didn't turn out to be as much of a
challenge as maybe
I had hoped for especially in the later
sections of the park the Dutch section
in particular I'm quite happy with how
it turned out try to really get that
cozy charming look to it and while there
is so many different things that I don't
like about this park which I'm try to
not go on about it was in the end also
really good learning experience
especially about the details that I
wanted to get in before I move on to
larger things again like L Fame and my
Christie Valley so yeah that is
basically what I wanted to say about
that
to get on the topic of this video a
little bit again most of the stuff which
I'm doing here is pretty much is filling
up the area so you could see I was
adding some lights in there some benches
I'm actually quite happy with how the
lights turn out even though they are
more or less a copy of the lights of the
eclectic Palace and a lot very open
foliage since this is a new area of the
park and especially these parts between
the paths and between the buildings kind
of I wanted to make them look as just
very newly planted areas where the
bushes still kind of need to grow and
where the trees are still very low I'm
not going to try and turn that into a
poem so yeah that's all just very simple
stuff but what I also wanted to do is
actually change the park border and you
can probably tell I'm trying to fit this
as much as I can within a rectangular
shape since part of what I wanted to do
with this park realism wise is actually
give it a real Park border and try and
stay within that and also have it have a
sort of realistic Park borders so it's
very square and it had to fit the park
in quite in a very compact way within
that border so that's why I also see me
replacing some of the borders of the
park or instead of an offensive to mark
the border have some sort of trees in a
row stuff like that
and also I wanted to cover up some of
the entrances to the rides that I still
had because those things are just even
though they're nice I don't really like
having those yellow gates everywhere and
with this last one I just figured if you
can't beat them you can just join them
so instead of covering the entire thing
with some sort of house decided to just
cover up the yellow
with wood and put a whirly rig over it
which actually turned out to be quite
nice as well if I were to still have
more time to develop this bike where the
whirly rig right now stands would have
been a windmill which was more or less
the idea that that would close off the
facade and sort of make a very large
weenie for the Dutch area because as
small as this point is I still wanted to
get some weenies in but um alas that
would take a lot of time and I don't
have that much time so I ended up just
placing a quick whirly Rick which does
have the advantage of bringing another
flat ride into the park because
especially with the park this small you
want to keep it quite dense with the
flat rides and things like that so it's
good to have at least three flat rides
and a roller coaster and a restaurant
into the Dutch area so there's really
enough stuff into in this area to go
around with and the rest of this is more
filling up the foliage closer to the
park border though there is still quite
a lot of more dense foliage a bit more
Foresti and I wanted to fill in many of
these open places with a lot of bushes
but that's really just about the foliage
which is boring now the last thing that
I still wanted to make is some sort of
thing around this ride not necessarily
because it's really that necessary I
could have just left the key open but
the way that the Dutch area is laid out
it's really like once or a very large
winding plaza on different levels and
all around that there are likes and
larger structures so you've got the
pirate ship on one side you've got some
buildings on the other side you've got
the coaster on yet another side which
really closes in the class but it really
felt very open and like it didn't really
end properly on this side since there
isn't really anything that's very tall
here so I wanted to put a building over
the queue which also has the added
advantage of being able to cover up the
yellow gate again so that's another
problem out of the way and it just makes
the entire area
coming come together a bit more I think
and this was more or less my idea of
what I wanted to do in the original
planning the original planning was to
have a round ride at that same place and
have a row of facades behind it but this
works more or less in the same way at
least when the most of the buildings is
concerned so that finishes off this area
of the park quite nicely and the last
couple of things that I still need to do
around here and this is really the very
final part of this video I won't film
any of the adding extra trees around the
park or anything like that you'll just
see that in the final video of the park
don't worry
but um yeah just some extra foliage over
here bit fancier than the regular
foliage with some flowers and things
like that and very last but not least a
bit of a backstage area I realised I
didn't have an actual staff building yet
so a building which is really behind all
of the scenery and hidden by a lot of
smart foliage and houses over here to
actually have some sort of retreats for
the staff to work at so the very last
thing which I wanted to do which you
might not even see in the final video
but it definitely sort of makes its
impact if you look at the park from
above as a bird at bird's eye view is a
small staff building just a quick
rectangular building with I don't know
what kind of retreat staff members would
usually have with their little cafe or a
toilets or something like that and cover
that up with a bit of foliage and that
is pretty much it so thank you guys for
watching this series and I hope to see
you guys in the final video and on to
the next one